[Music]  you remember how we used to get the  raptors in the truck yeah yeah  you're up no  like a last minute dive roll i don't  roll you'll be fine  i never got the timing right  no wait a minute any minute now  no  no  no  blue had a baby that's impossible  hey girl  you look just like your mother  [Music]  genetic power has now been unleashed  we made a terrible mistake  the doomsday clock might be about out of  time  if our world's gonna survive what  matters is what we do now  i can use your expertise  you comment or what  a baby raptor i made a promise we would  bring her home  you made a promise  to a dinosaur yeah what  [Music]  everybody hold on to somebody  that can't be right  what is that biggest carnivore the world  has ever seen  not so bad  [Music]  you